hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna do some work with our navigation
so this will be more proper front-end
work I know we've been doing some
back-end work lately but today we're
gonna get back to the front end and I
think I finally sorted out all the
issues that I've been having with stream
quality so I should be running now
assuming that your internet connection
is fast enough it should run 1080p 60
frames frames per second the problem
didn't have anything to do with my
settings and OBS
it was with my computer's so what I
found was depending on what I had
running I would drop a lot of frames so
I've turned off all the programs that I
don't need and I've closed out most of
the tabs that I could and I tested out
I'd closed everything it would work I'd
open more stuff and it didn't work so so
far this works I tested earlier for a
little while and it worked the whole
time I tested it just this past half
hour and only for a few seconds that had
dropped frames so I think we're good
and I don't know really what changed the
only thing I did differently on my
computer other than closed out a lot of
things which we already tried before was
I downloaded the latest update for the
Mac OS so there was when I came in this
morning there's an update available so I
just went ahead and did that straight
off and that that seemed to do something
because my fan wasn't running you know a
basically it's been running really hard
the whole time I've been using it for
the last week so that's all
I'll sort it out hopefully and so we'll
get started I don't have anything going
on so depending on how the stream goes
you might be able to do a longer stream
today we'll just see so let me check the
live chat here for a second not sure
I'll see this one all right so if you
you aren't gonna be able to watch live
that's cool thanks for stopping in and
say hi and as you all know you can
always check out the recording later
savage banana says howdy complete noob
here done a few bits on free code camp
about to do a boot camp looking forward
to watching you this evening even though
I probably won't understand now I'll be
soaking it in alright awesome thanks for
watching and feel free to ask as many
questions as you want don't worry if you
think it's a new question or something
I'm happy to explain something and go
over anything that you need I just said
the streams going well Peter says it's
looking clean - awesome
the ninja says this channel is dope
thank you I appreciate that
a boo says will you start coding now I
will start coding and as always I know
there's some of you that don't like the
talking part and you just like the
coding part so if that's the case I mean
I really love when you can watch live
that's awesome
but if if it does bother you all the
talking then feel free to watch the
recording and you can just skip ahead
and basically any time you see just my
face and no code then you're safe to
skip that and that's totally fine I
understand
there's not really enough time in the
day to listen to me go on and on anyway
alright so let's get started and let's
change my screen so I'll explain what
we're gonna do briefly and then we'll
get to it so we've already talked about
what we want to do with this navigation
and previous streams in case you've
forgotten or you didn't catch that
stream here's what's gonna happen when
we click on one of these links it's
gonna open up this side drawer and we're
gonna have the same links as top-level
navigation here so it'll say it won't
say in box it'll say about academics
admissions faith in life and they'll all
be expandable so open up this side
navigation with the correct item
expanded and all the options shown for
instance if I clicked about the about
option would be expanded everything else
would be not expanded so that's the goal
what I want to do now the reason I
decided to switch and do this today
instead of working on some of the stuff
we have been working on is well twofold
one the stuff that we've been working on
lately is gonna get real repetitive
we've worked out a lot of the you know
kind of tough problems that we've had
mostly to do with routing and bringing
data over now it's just a matter of
taking the time to actually do that I
don't want to make boring streams of me
just constantly doing the same thing
over and over again and the second
reason is I'm starting to show people
this site so sure my Boston site last
week and one of the things that we went
over is the menu and I went to click
these and I remembered oh we never made
that work and he had asked it was a bit
we had I discussed it before of my boss
but it was a long time ago so I had to
go over again when we click this then
it's gonna do that so I think it would
be a lot easier when I start to show it
to more people to just have it working
even if the links don't even go anywhere
yet which they won't because we haven't
built out you know most of the site yet
but I want the functionality to work I
think it'll be a lot easier to just show
people than to explain it so that's what
we're gonna do and yeah let's check out
the component it's been a while since
we've even worked on these so I don't
remember
we set up in the components and I'm
gonna be looking at them with fresh eyes
basically so we have our app bar
component which is what we're will have
all right now our app bar and our drawer
are gonna be the two components we're
gonna be working in today the most I
already have this running
let me get n grog started for you all
and I'm gonna paste the link here in the
live chat and you all can click on that
link go to it and let's see all right it
looks like it is working great so anyway
if you're not familiar with n drop
just click the link you'll be able to
see this site as we're working on it and
test out the changes you can inspect it
in dev tools so it'll be a lot more
interactive if you're able to do that
all right so let's check out if we have
anything set up already so here's all
our font icons now this component could
definitely use some refactoring to clean
it up a bit that's gonna happen at some
point but my opinion is if you have a
deadline you have to meet you get
everything working first you can always
go back and refactor later but if you
spend all your time refactoring and you
won't get the project done nobody's
gonna care the users not gonna care when
you try to explain to them about
refactoring the streams lagging again
isn't it No
why's it lagging maybe n grub all right
you know what let me shut down n drop
for a second and see if that made a
difference because that was really the
only different thing that we did right
I've changed nothing else
my how the videos lagging again
have
try to make did I do anything else only
thing I did anything
No
well hi what what is it happen now what
else is running on my machine this is
nothing I guess I could turn off Spotify
let's turn Spotify out I'm not gonna
have my music it's just butterflies off
I guess that wasn't it I'm gonna turn
chrome canary off was that what I was
using I didn't realize that was a canary
window and that's it I can't I can't
turn anything else off
all right I guess I could drop
all right in my back
let me know if you can hear me OBS is
saying that everything is fine
alright cool alright looks like this
will work now and I'm gonna turn my
Spotify back on this that was not the
problem
all right cool I really thought I had
that figured out this time
oh well try again tomorrow
unless I really like figure out
something significant that fixes this
I'm just gonna stream at 720p again
tomorrow not not risk it Savage banana
says try streaming at 30 frames per
second yeah maybe I'll maybe I can try
1080p but at 30 frames per second see if
that'll work I actually didn't even see
a setting though for the frames per
second which was weird it's possible I'm
just looking in the wrong place
Oh
all right so let's go let me start a
timer so I can know when to come back
and answer some questions
I'm gonna go I think this is hard [ __ ]
right hard [ __ ] this is yours right the
SH or pompom out on Sh it's the this one
I was using using three different
Pomodoro timers and two of them from
that you all made and one of them that I
had been using using for years I don't
actually I don't know by years how long
about no Pomodoro definitely more than a
year
potentially not longer into the alright
see
alright let me make this a bit bigger so
you can see especially now that we've
dropped the video quality a little bit
so hopefully that's large enough for you
let me know if it's not so let's find
our our menu see if we have any click
handlers already on here that we can
work with otherwise we'll make some see
this is a search alright great so here's
where we have this so it looks like all
right it looks like we're using the
typography component that comes with
material UI to create an a tag and
alright so right now just has an H Drive
okay
I suppose we don't even really need it
to be a link but for now let's let's see
where the let me bring this back up
I forgot we shut it down localhost 3 and
let me try to bring in grog back up
because I don't think that was actually
the problem all right so the links now
in the live chat
all right I was just inspecting the this
this is the Li and this is just the a
the a tag so I was wondering what would
be better to put the link on or to you
know have the Clint area
all right let me know what you all think
I guess it would be either way it really
doesn't matter I suppose except we may
have a slightly larger area would we no
we wouldn't
I think it would be the same all right
sue doesn't matter
so let's try to do a an on-click
should we do non clicker non touch thing
I was looking at a project that I did
earlier and we were using on touch tap
instead of on click but I can't remember
why
so I'm just gonna go with on click and
what we can always change it back if we
want okay savage banana found the
settings for the frames per second and
it's on the it's in the video section
you know that that makes sense now
I remember a while ago I had to go to
the video section to change some stuff
and I thought I remember cuz I thought
it was it was weird that it was in there
instead of the streaming all right harsh
it says that was material UI 0.26 it's
fixed with with one okay so we had to
use it in a previous version but you
don't have to use it now awesome
thanks for that hard [ __ ] all right so
let's say
group inside drawer this thought open
side drawer alright so we haven't made
it yet but we need to make it and we
need to have we're gonna pass it
something huh yeah we have to pass it
something
all right so this side and I said
we
all right so I'm just going to use the
name which in this case is faith in life
I'm gonna pass that in as a string we'll
have to figure out maybe a better way to
do this we don't have to manually type
it out but just to get it working first
this should work for us as well
obviously I'd rather have a lot of this
stuff in data files and then bring it in
instead of having it all hard-coded hmm
I would have thought we already had some
things built out for this all right I
was thinking for some reason we had to
have some type of click Handler to open
up the side drawer but we're pulling it
in pulling that in from
somewhere else I guess
okay
we think if we're gonna need to watch
this before
sorry I'm just gonna think out how this
works we need so we need to be able to
share what's going on with two
components the app bar in the drawer so
I'm assuming they're both tied together
in the layout for a drawer so I'm just
wondering if this should all live in the
layout which is where we're getting
double drawer from so that's as expected
as opposed yeah so maybe this is where
the the where that should live
yeah that makes sense actually we
already have an expansion for the drawer
no click so the handle click we have in
the drawer already expands the items so
this is really what we want to use
anyway let's pull this up into layout
and then from app bar we should be able
to just call this function and at the
same time so we'll call this function
and we'll call the drawer toggle so
we'll basically use what we already have
I think that'll be the best way to do it
all right John has some social faith in
life link text should have
white-space:nowrap
all right cool thank you I'll add that
in I want to do this first why it's in
my mind so I don't lose what I just what
I just thought of all right so let's
grab our handle click stay notice the
state of items
all right so let me see how we need to
pull this out I'm gonna try to go I
don't know if I could put these two
side-by-side
maybe if I close this it would work move
try it out layout okay
okay John has a question that has to do
with what we're about to attempt says is
it the best practice for a stateful
furthest up container to control any
actions below it Pass with props if you
need to share if you need to share the
state then yes it should be in the
parent but you shouldn't get crazy with
it so you shouldn't be passing things up
like five components like five parent
components and that's where things like
redux come in and help simplify things
so that you don't have to pass
everything up from child to parent
several levels up because then it can be
really confusing and difficult
especially if you go in to change
something it trying to remember and go
in and every component and make sure
you're still passing things down
properly is can be difficult so I guess
so we're not really using Redux we're
using what is it hard should help me out
here because harshest the one was
telling me about it so Apollo now
handles state in a similar way to Redux
so I guess we could do some of that I
haven't worked with it exactly yet but I
know that there was some significant
update to where he can handle stuff but
for now we only need to go up one
component just to the parent so I'm
totally fine with that if there's some
reason why you all think that we should
try to use something else to manage
state instead of you know just passing
it with with props then I'm definitely
open to suggestions but I think this
should work out in this case all right
so here's our layout component this is
our parent so what we want to do is add
our handle click yeah our handle click
we're gonna add this over here I'm gonna
briefly keep the handle click here so
that way
I can see the original and if we edit
this I can just go back quickly but then
eventually we will just remove this so
what we want to do is pass down the
handle click so just like we're we're
handling we're passing down this toggle
drawer so we have this toggle drawer and
we're also passing down the state of
this so we have this drawer
true or false whether that's open or
closed we're gonna do the same thing we
need to we're going to say handle click
yes we call it in
let's make this a little bit more
descriptive because that's we're gonna
have multiple click events going on so
let's call it expand menu yeah that
works
expand menu and four expand menu this
such states
so let's make open an item's
that's odd how does this so I want to
see how this behaves now we only have
one item alright what I'm worried about
here is our open items is just a true or
false so I'm wondering if that works
with multiple items so let's let's try
that check that out quickly
this
alright let's throw this in here just to
see
okay it's as I thought right now this is
opening and closing everything which is
not what we want we're going to change
that
all right it's fine it's gonna be a
little bit more complex all right here's
so we can do
what I'm thinking is so number one I
want to separate this out into its own
component this is way too much to have
all of this in this component so the
entire for sure will grab this whole
list item and then the collapse
component that comes with it and then we
may even want to separate out this
collapse as well
yeah all right let's do that this is
already a bit of a mess all right so
let's open up a new tab here that's
this tied on down to
it's
claps all right now here's what I we're
gonna have to wrap this in a div
hopefully it doesn't mess up how this
works or how it looks
yeah I don't I don't see how we could do
that differently so let's let's make
call this
so how we do it yeah
all right great now we can copy and
paste this down
right on and let's give it
we need reacts with styles and link for
sure we need link well you know we use
the link I thought we were but now that
I see it not all right
we need lists yeah we do need list and
list item collapse
expand less explore more
[Music]
you need the divider I don't think so at
least not yet
alright let's save this component we're
gonna call this item
yeah alright what did I mess up
something oh that's right I need to put
this in a dip
oh yes this is just indentation which
right
six in that Frodo six oh and and froze
see that alright great classes is not
defined so we need to make sure we bring
that over those classes
oops alright the timer went off so let
me stop here I'm gonna take five minutes
I'm gonna answer any questions that you
all have and then we'll come back and
finish this up as much as we can also
when I come back from the five minute
break maybe I'll take time to explain a
little bit of what just happened if
you're not familiar with react then this
was probably confusing there's a timer
all right I'm gonna scroll up to the top
and and try to get through as many
questions and comments as I can if I
don't get your question or comment
during this five minute break I will
most likely get to it in the next one at
the end of the stream I'll get to all
the comments and questions so just be
patient if you can't stick around you
can always check out the recording of
this later on it'll be available in this
channel the free code camp YouTube
channel
Samir asks hi Jesse I'm new to react
where can I start you can always check
out the official react documentation
like on the react website it's not bad I
remember when I was first just knew and
started reading it it was over my head
but they do have some beginner tutorials
on there so depending on how good you
already are with JavaScript you may do
better with that than I did free code
camp has a beta curriculum that you can
preview and work on they have some react
lessons on there I have not gone through
them myself
but I see other people on Twitter have
you know talked about going through them
so they seem to be good code Academy has
an in-browser react course and I think
what else I think those are the main
resources if you want to spend money on
a course I did go through the Udacity
react nano degree if you want to know
more about that check out my channel I
did do a short video
of what my review of that nanodegree
program so I'm not going to go over it
again since I already have that
available but you can check that out the
link to my channel is in the description
for this video so that's where I would
start out now
if there are also some videos on this
channel that go over you react basics so
you can check those out as well and
you're more than welcome to watch these
streams and I'll do my best to explain
everything be sure to ask a lot of
questions because I'll answer as much as
I possibly can
yes let's see the Konya says why
programmers haven't got girls i I have a
wife so ha
I'm programmer and I have a wife so I'm
not sure I'm not sure why other
programmers might not have them I don't
really know I mean I don't know that
there's anything inherent to programmers
that would make them not have girls I
think it's just like a joke I guess if
you spend all your time inside
programming then you might be a lot more
pale than people like maybe I don't know
I'm just messing around now I don't
really know the Ninja says in reply says
who jesse has a house full of hot shakes
that's not I would say singular one hot
shake my wife is very hot so I don't
have a house who I just have one and
then I do have daughters but nobody say
that they're there ha don't talk about
my daughters like that
my suckers are six and one and a half so
there's still a tiny little people right
now let's see
all right there's a lot of comments
about the stream whenever it was lagging
King Mobile says hi to all hey how's it
going thanks for watching
Superman says can you give me your
opinion on view Jay s eye I have not
used you I haven't even really seen
tutorials about you but I've seen a lot
of people who developers who I do
respect that I respect their opinion I
think they're good developers and they
really like view so my opinion on it now
is just I've heard good things about it
it seems like it's a good framework so
if you want to give it a shot I say go
for it I'd like to try it out at some
point but I don't have any plans to do
it right now I think that I'm still not
where I want to be with my skills and
react so the limited time that I have to
be able to you know put into kind of
training and studying more I'm gonna put
into react right now and you know maybe
one day I'll go with you but I don't
have anything against you I haven't to
be honest with you I haven't heard
anything negative about view it's all
been good stuff so if anybody has used
view would like to put your opinion in
please put it in the live chat now if
you're watching the recording later on
go ahead and put it in the comments and
I think that would be helpful for
anybody that's you know wondering about
view if somebody who's actually used it
would weigh in preferably somebody
that's used you and react to give a
maybe a comparison all right so my
five-minute timer is up I'm gonna draw
it down quickly where I left off in the
live chat help me get back to it after
our our next session
all right
oh hey I just noticed like 10 minutes
ago Quincy stopped in I'm not sure if
he's still here so but if you are hey
Quincy thanks for the retweet I
appreciate that
deal if you don't know who Quincy is
he's the the founder and head of free
code camp so I wouldn't be doing a
stream here if it weren't for Quincy and
so I always appreciate when Quincy stops
in it's always exciting and go ahead and
follow Quincy on on Twitter if you want
to find out everything that's going on
with free code camp he's always always
tweeting about all the different things
are doing so that's so much going on
here free code camp now you know we've
had the forum for a long time we have
the youtubes we have two YouTube
channels now one for talks and one you
know this channel that we're on and have
a medium publication with blogs of a
podcast now the new beta curriculum is
being worked on and it's gonna come out
soon I'm probably missing some other
things that we're doing but there's just
so much with free code camp so if you if
you haven't checked out the rest of what
is there then you know please please
check it out there's so much more and
better stuff than just what I'm doing
here on the stream all right so one
problem that we had before we stopped is
that when we put more than one
collapsible item in here right now the
way we have it set up they both open and
close at the same time so we need to fix
that but first we're gonna clean some
stuff up so we've extracted out all the
the code we need to make one of these
these elements click and everything
below it included we've extracted that
out into its own component and we're not
we don't have everything ready yet we
see we still have some little red
squiggly lines which means we have
errors mainly these aren't defined so we
need to
you define let's see
stylus thing I'm wondering if any of
these had to do with image form control
nested I think nested yeah we need to
pull the nested class but I don't think
we'll need any of the other ones so
let's bring this in now and then we'll
remove what we don't need
let's double check yeah that was the
only place we were using classes and we
need to bring in also ones classes
oops a new version of Java is available
I do not want Java ROM you later how do
I still have a job on my computer anyway
anyway it popped up on my other screen
[Music]
I think the open referred to the drawer
yeah it did so we don't need open
we don't need toggle drawer let's just
bring in classes wonderful and style so
all right so now we have everything that
we need and we may be able to get rid of
this let's get rid of this and see
that's the viz in that list item all
right great we can get rid of this this
was just that that second one we brought
in
okay so that's shortened up our
component a little bit nice we may even
pull this out at some point I'm okay
with it there for now this is that
search so this is our logo at the top
and this is that search input so that's
we're talking about so you see
everything below it now has been taken
out so first let's just try to put this
back in and see if it if it works oh no
we didn't have we need this toggled for
all right we will have to pass toggle
drawdown so let's put that back in here
toggle drawer and what we calling the
other one right now let's handle click
but we don't want it to be called handle
click right we want it to be open item
all right yeah we're gonna call it open
item
all right so we have our handle click is
now gonna be actually our handle click
is gonna get passed down as a prop from
our layout right I'm you know what I'm
gonna check the live chat so I if you
have any questions put them in the live
chat I'm gonna do a better job of
checking back in there to make sure that
I'm not losing you feel free to ask
questions I'm just going to really
quickly scan through the last few
comments
okay rook says that handle click
function please change that set state
call to the function version ok we're so
Rooker we're talking about this handle
click just to be sure if it's this one
just let me know that I have the right
one this this may be the only one that
we've seen but we're actually going to
take this out completely from here and
we're gonna move it up to layout
let me grab that we may have done it did
we do it already
I think we did expand menu is that what
we did we did I went over here and I
called it expand menu
all right so rook is saying there is a
recommended way to update the state
based on previous state and so let's
let's do that let's add States let's do
that here just to show if you can't see
the live chat now I'll kind of type it
out for you
so this is our previous state and so we
can we're gonna pass in our previous
state and we can update our object so
then we would put what open say for your
city's primary music so our open items
is gonna be
there's a be the same
so we do it like this open items equals
would need to be something like this and
rooks explaining this avoids issues with
set state being a synchronous and
batching set state calls by default okay
great
open item appreciated on alright awesome
so this was the correct yeah this is the
correct way thanks for uh I appreciate I
appreciate you pointing that out that's
cool yeah I am I knew that we could get
the previous state I'd never used it
before I didn't realize that there was
better performance with this so I'm glad
I'll try to keep this in mind and use it
it'll probably take me a while before
I'm used to this way but I will try to
use it would it would this way be the
best way just by default oh no what I
did would this be the best way by
default or should I stick with kind of
the normal way and less I I was already
using it up here I probably didn't write
this one of you probably wrote this and
mer I just merged the pool request but I
didn't realize those are using it also I
don't need these parens parentheses e8
Emily just avoids issues when you change
state based on previous day okay cool so
I will do my best to learn this way and
keep using it
alright so except this expand menu you
know what I want to say expand item I
think I like that better because really
it's a menu item it happens that what
submenu inside it but I think I like
item better since we're calling this a
drawer item I expand expand item
hmm
see
okay Brooke says you also get access to
props in that function as a second
argument it's not using a handler right
now all right cool that's useful all
right so right now the expanding and
collapsing is was handled in our drawer
by state we had open items so what we're
gonna do now is alright let's do it like
this States equals open items why is
that defaulted to truth
you think you'd want it to be defaulted
to false right
I wanted false maybe just for an example
we had it defaulted to true alright so
I'm gonna put that in here but then I'm
gonna do
yeah that's how we'll do it wait a
second
not just confused myself okay let me
explain what I was what I'm thinking
here why I just confused myself so our
problem was we had both opening at the
same time both items would open and
close at the same time so my solution I
was thinking is let's separate onto
another component let's handle state and
that component and then each component
each expandable menu would handle its
own state and that would work but the
problem is that we also need to be able
to change the state of that item from
another component it's going to be our
app bar component so that that was the
issue
so it's easy to do it in here if all the
states internal the hard part is getting
the click to work all right we'll take
it one step at a time let's break it
down first let's just get this to work
we're gonna pretend right now like we
don't have to do the other step and
that'll just simplify things we'll get
it to work then we can go to step two
and figure out how to change the state
from outside this component alright so
what we'll do then is
all right so for now we know we're not
gonna keep it in here but for now let's
just put this in here just to make sure
that we haven't messed anything up when
we move this component over so we should
save that that should work and then here
we're going to add in bringing in
components whoops
yeah and sure we are right
yeah
so I'm thinking out loud a bit I've been
working so much with the importing data
and things I haven't actually worked
with react components like this for for
a while probably like definitely before
before Christmas all right so we're
gonna import drawer item and it's in the
same folder so we just need to do dot
slash drawer item and then down here we
can add a few drawer items to the bottom
of our list the item
it's alright three of them in there you
saved that save that and let's see
whoops I guess those colors are right I
think my colors are a little off from
what I used to use in my other editor so
sometimes I think I have errors and I
really don't
let's see whoops I didn't want to save
this yet all right I got accidentally
saying that
all right cool
all right so it still opens no all right
so our clicks don't work all right I'm
glad we we tried this out first because
we did something in the clicks don't
even work
all right so let's take a look at our
item so we do have a state the state's
open items oops
you stayed open items that's probably
our problem no okay so I thought that
was the problem because we we're trying
to change something in state this day
for you stay all right that looks fine
let's try out expand item
expand expand item oh that's right we
don't sit in props right now and then
where's our own clique
yeah our on-click should say this expand
item
all right so there we go now it works
and since each component is handling its
own state then they open independently
awesome ok so that works the reason it
didn't work at first was because one I
wasn't even changing the right state I
was I just had the word open here I
didn't have open items so that was a
problem and then also our on clique was
trying to call a function called handle
clique which didn't even exist because
we changed the name to expand item so
those are the the two issues all right
so now that that works let's take the
next step and see if we can when we
click one of these have this open and
then have a change so I'd say the first
step is let's just make it so that when
we click one of these the drawer opens
we'll try to do that we'll test that if
that works then we'll move on and try to
do this and we'll see how much time we
have I'm going to commit this right now
since we've kind of got to a point where
things are stable and they work and it
is an improvement over what we had we're
not all over there yet but I think this
is a good point to commit I'm gonna do a
git add so what I just did was I added
any new files and basically I added any
files to be ready to be committed and
then I'm gonna do git commit em which
means is I'm gonna put my commit message
in that's what the M does and I'm gonna
say create
create your item component that's pretty
much what we did alright now it's gonna
run through all the tests so if you want
to contribute to the project hahaha
we gotta hit with these this is I'm glad
this kind of hat this happen like this
so if you want to contribute to the
project when you go to commit which I
encourage anyone who wants to contribute
please do especially if you haven't
contributed to a project before and
github the project we do on the stream I
think are a great chance for you to just
get started so I'm not gonna get upset
if you do a pull request and it's it
doesn't work I'll try to help you
through it if you have any questions let
me know I've had a handful of people
submit their first pull request on the
things that we work on in the stream and
I'm always really happy when that
happens so if you want to submit a PR
let me know if you need help I'm here to
help you but if you do on pretty much
all our projects we have some automated
testing and linting and formatting so a
lot of what you see here is is that
going on but I messed up so it's not
gonna let me commit until I fix this so
let's fix it and run it again and it's
gonna check everything and make sure I
did it right this is kind of a good like
safety net so that code that obviously
doesn't work doesn't get into the
project it makes it a little bit easier
for me to review the pull requests
because there's certain things I know
are already gonna be there and I don't
have to check on so let's see where
we're at so it tells us now it's es lint
has found some errors so these are
basically like errors that break the
rules of the eslint so obviously these
errors haven't caused our application to
crash but we don't want this kind of
stuff in our code we want it cleaned up
so we have some some things that we've
defined but never used so we don't want
to do that so let's find out where it's
at
they're all in this drawer dot J s
component so we don't have to look in
one place was just good and it tells us
exactly exactly where
they all are so let's check it out line
by line I'm going to shrink this a
little bit so we can see this is our
drawer da jazz component let's go up
here and we have line 6 7 8 & 9 so on
line 6 and it's actually highlighting it
here in red so if I would have been more
careful in check before I tried to
commit we would have seen it but let's
get rid of that list item since we're
not using it anymore and these are all
things that we took out and moved over
to this component that's why we don't
need them anymore and now I'm just gonna
get rid of all these lines and save okay
I can verify that everything's still
working by going back to my project
alright great it still works and now I
don't have to type everything in again
I'm just gonna hit the up arrow key on
my keyboard and it brings up that last
message that get commit message this
will save you a lot of time I was
talking to somebody yesterday who didn't
know about that on the command line and
it's always great when you first learn
about that and also the autocomplete
like if you hit tab it autocompletes
when you first learn about that it like
changes your world it was so cool to see
somebody like learn that for the first
time so I'm gonna hit enter again it's
gonna run through our test let's make it
a bit bigger there we go so I made it
through prettier which auto formats I
made it through es lint which that's
what I got caught at last time now let's
actually running tests so it's opening
up a browser it's loading the page and
checking to make sure certain elements
are actually on the page so you can't
see it now the browser opened up on my
other screen but actually I just saw all
these tabs open in the browser and
different pages in the site load you
don't have to have it open up there's
some options you can run it so you don't
see it but you can see it checked our
faculty page we don't have tests for all
our pages yet that's one of the areas
where maybe I should make some issues in
the github repo anybody that really
wants to write the test feel free
but we did test we tested three pages
our faculty and it says this page can be
seen at this you are a faculty / some ID
so whatever ID we want to test and it
displays the correct data the index can
be seen at the correct URL which is the
root and then page two can be seen at
slash page right so we pass all our
tests now we're ready to commit or ready
to push this so we're gonna get push
origin and we could type in master here
since we want to push it to the master
branch but we don't have to we can just
use the shorthand hit enter it'll
automatically push to master I do need
to put in my ID since I restarted my
computer earlier so let me my other
screen here I'm gonna open up LastPass
if you're not using a password manager
like LastPass I do recommend it that way
you can use super long ridiculous
passwords and you don't have to remember
them you have to remember one you're
super long ridiculous LastPass password
but then all your other ones are covered
hmm for some reason LastPass is not
opening
what did I do I'll meet you two opening
a different window no
all right amuse
last time
okay rook says you don't even have to
use git push origin you can just use get
push and that will work that's really
cool I didn't know that I'm gonna have
to log into the desktop version of
LastPass since my extension isn't
working my Chrome extension when I was
shutting down clone chrome windows
before that from the task manager and
Chrome maybe I accidentally did
something that messed up LastPass I
don't know maybe you should go to the
Chrome extensions page after I just gave
this big deal on everybody use LastPass
then now it doesn't work
I can open up the options for LastPass I
just can't open less
Oh
Harshit says are you and LastPass
premium I am in LastPass premium I could
just open it on my phone and type in the
password I guess let me do that I was
just trying to get out of typing in that
big password but
[Music]
all right let me type this in
all right that should work what
all right well let's try to just type
git push let me try to type it again
maybe I did it wrong
yeah it worked this done awesome sorry
for the delay okay so that's that's
there and that's pushed to get up so you
all can see all the code that we just
did you can check it out yourself you
can clone the project contribute use it
for whatever you want everything's
totally open-source and we use the MIT
license you can do whatever you want I
will say like the obviously the logo
doesn't fall under that right that's the
university's logo and then like
university images but the code itself is
MIT all right let me let me set my
five-minute time remember though through
some questions and then figure out
whether or not we want to continue with
this and try to get some more to work or
maybe want to say that for tomorrow
stream so if you have an opinion about
that let me know I know it can be a long
time to watch a stream we've been going
for almost an hour and a half now so let
me know if you'd rather have me split it
up and do some today and some tomorrow
or just do it all today
let's see Dinesh asked are you a react
developer I guess so I mean officially
I'm a front-end developer and I do a lot
of react stuff so I think it would be
accurate to say I'm a react developer if
anyone disagrees with that let me know
I'm not really sure what qualifies
someone to be reactive L appear but I
develop things with react John Hansen
says so I should mostly pass up with
props in the functional dumb components
if a component view container needs
state to make its standalone component
then let them hold their own functions
let me read that again
props yeah so you're you're stateless
functional components definitely just do
props right they they're not gonna have
state
yeah so if you need a if you need
something to have its own state you can
put the functions in there like we did
with these list items all right now
obviously either later today or tomorrow
we're gonna have to deal with the other
things that we wanted to do and it may
need to change but for now that was the
simplest way to get the behavior that we
wanted that each component handles its
own State
John Hanson says jesse is a react king I
don't know about that I'd be happy if I
was like I don't know
a react Duke what are all the titles of
royalty right maybe I'm down a little
lower then that says as I can see on
both the screens you might be working on
HTML and some j/s framework is that
correct which framework is of JavaScript
is it
it is react so we are using react
same country Becky
all right I mean so Quincy was in the
chat a little while ago and Quincy did
say we're just getting started exciting
things and the pipes for 2018 so that's
cool I'm excited to see what what
happens so I'm not in the loop with all
the secret free code camp new stuff
coming out so I'm just as excited as as
any of you might be see let's see Deb
Deb up Brio - Deb uh Priya so let me
know if I mispronounced that but anyway
they say hey I was making a Twitter
clone with react Jes and material I but
I couldn't get the Twitter's navigation
icons like Oh Michel on etc how do I get
those icons hmm within that like my cone
is like for Twitter no I accidentally
closed out my my YouTube window
so I always wondered if my stream would
still work if I close out of YouTube and
it looks like it did still work let me
know it did the stream stopped at all
look like a few seconds ago
see
I'm trying to look at the the bottom of
the live chat and see if it stops
all right cool that was really weird
so I accidentally closed the tab and now
it says that it looks like my stream has
restarted from my admin screen because
it's saying I've only been streaming for
one minute
but based on what you are telling me I
guess it didn't stop at all I'm just
worried because I don't want there to be
two videos of this this stream later on
so as long as that doesn't happen I
think it's it's okay so anyway the
question was about the icons for Twitter
so the reason I accidentally close my
windows because I was going to open a
new tab and look at the Twitter icons so
I could better answer the question and I
accidentally closed out YouTube I don't
know where you would get the icons for
Twitter they may not be available for
public use so I would just be careful
about that you could certainly get some
icons that would do that like yoga
there's a home icon right you could
probably find a little icon of a house
somewhere it might not be exactly what's
on Twitter but I would just be careful
to find out if you're allowed to use the
Twitter icons or not and I mean you may
be able I don't know if you'd be able to
check in the code if they would have a
comment somewhere in there or even I
don't know if these are SVG's or what I
just just opened dev tools to see no no
it looks like a font icon all right so
what is using I guess their own font
icon set for that so maybe do a search
for Twitter font icons
all right my times up I'm just I'm gonna
go down through how about we'll do this
I'm gonna go down three I'm going to
answer all the questions and everything
once we get to the end I'm gonna see how
I feel how tired I am streaming takes a
lot out of you it really realistically
I'm just sitting here talking and typing
but like mentally it's draining to try
to focus on the code and the live chat
and talk so I might not be up for doing
workout after this but there's a lot in
the live chat so I want to make sure I
get to all your questions we can always
finish what we're doing here tomorrow so
let me
alright Stevens's Jesse just a quick
question having a hard time learning
JavaScript any ideas on what I should do
I get the concepts just not how to use
it maybe if you need a little help about
how to use it maybe check out some like
practical projects that use it maybe
where they walk you through some of it
so maybe like a video where it walks
through making a or an actual project
would be good and then maybe you could
go along with the video like type things
out along with the video or you know
then go from watching the video to
trying to do it on your own in your own
way something like that might help you
make the connection between you know
being able to do like some of the
algorithm challenges to actually being
able to build things on your own so I
know there are some videos on this
channel I know Bo has some videos and
some other people have videos on
actually making project step-by-step
that use JavaScript so maybe try one out
some of them might be too advanced so
just you know try a few of them out and
see what you can do with it alright
that's probably the best way to do
things right I think that's like natural
learning for people even when we're
little we learn by watching other people
doing things and then we try it out
ourselves so I think that's that's
everybody's different but that might be
a more natural ways to watch somebody
else do it and then try it out as you
get confident then you can do your thing
and and be more creative with it so
anyway I hope that advice works Stephen
all right try it out if it doesn't you
know come on back ask me again maybe
some of the specific I can help you out
with if you need it
let's see
savage savage banana said pics of wife
or ride I said earlier let's talk about
my wife earlier in the stream so it
wouldn't be that order to figure out who
my wife is
we follow each other and like each other
stuff on Twitter and Instagram and
Facebook so if you really wanted to
figure out who my wife is and fine
pictures you could find it I'm not gonna
share them with you but it's not like
it's it's a secret let's see
Rick says catch you later have a meeting
see Rick thanks for joining us good luck
with your meeting ok we have a little
bit more context on Stephens question
earlier so Stephens working on the
Wikipedia viewer in the free code camp
challenges and just not getting it all
to work together the right way great and
on he'll had an idea of maybe ask
someone in the free code camp community
to do some peer programming it could
help I think that's a great idea that's
even better than watching a video if you
really need some some help you know
one-on-one help I'm sure there's a
there's some videos out there of people
actually building the Wikipedia viewer I
always have mixed feelings about that
when I go through the free code camp
challenges or anything like that I
always like to try to do it on my own
before I look at how anyone else did it
especially I don't mind as much looking
at the UI but looking at the code I'd
rather not do it
I suppose if I'm stuck on the same
problem for a really long time it makes
more sense to just look at how someone
else did it but but having somebody else
there with you to just help when you
need it I think would be preferable
someone asked about my code editor it is
Visual Studio code I do want to share
some good news I don't know if this
person wants this announced so I'm not
gonna say a name but somebody who
frequently is in the live chat all right
for these streams just got a developer
job and told me about it
within the last few days so really
excited about that congratulations you
know who you are if you're cool with me
saying your name just let me know
but anyway really excited that has
happened you know several times now
where you know someone who's watched the
live chat was able to get a job it's
always really cool when that happens so
any good news like that you know if you
if you're comfortable sharing I'd love
to hear about it it's like are you
really excited about about stuff like
that
I think it's cool when like we all
develop in our coding and you know our
careers develop so anyway again
congratulations just thought I'd share
that with you all a little little
inspiration if you are looking for a job
now people are getting jobs I'm not
saying that it has anything to do with
my stream it'd be cool if it did but
probably not but people are getting
hired it happens
keep at it and if you're looking for a
job it'll happen just keep keep trying
Stephen says do so how much the office
crypt don't need to know before I should
move to react my ultimate goal is to
jump in to react and in response John
says I went from jQuery to JavaScript in
about three months and I'm doing fairly
well with react after four months time
yeah I would say I've heard people say
that you should get really good with
JavaScript before you go to react and I
respectfully disagree with that opinion
I think once you know enough JavaScript
to understand the basics of react you're
okay to go and do react you will get
better with JavaScript as you do react
you'll use different parts of JavaScript
that you never use before when you do
react the only thing I would warn
against is don't just do react and
forget about the rest of JavaScript
actively try to learn more JavaScript
because one day no one will use react
probably not gonna be anytime soon but
at some point your career they'll
probably be some other thing and it'll
be a lot easier for you to go from react
to the other thing assuming the other
thing is JavaScript based which probably
will be but it'll be a lot easier for
you to go from react to the other thing
if you have a good foundation of
JavaScript so just to sum up my advice
is go for react as soon as you can start
understanding it but keep up your
learning of vanilla JavaScript along the
way let's see John Hanson says awesome
Jessie a good example of troubleshooting
and react thinking how I think I
appreciate it I felt like I felt like I
was in trouble there for a little bit
and I gotta looked over and so how many
people are watching uh all these people
are gonna think I don't know what I'm
doing but that's kind of the draw of the
stream right to see me struggle through
but I was rusty I felt really rusty
doing
act stuff I was just forgetting like
simple things so that long like winter
break just I I guess I forgot a lot more
than I thought I did but that through it
we did it helped once I try to break it
up into smaller steps so that's good a
good tip break things up into small
steps one at a time you'll have logical
places to do a commit and break it up
and you feel less overwhelmed
miss miss Sally's says I didn't
understand I'm not sure what you didn't
understand if you're still watching
could you let me know like more
specifics about what you didn't
understand I'd be happy to go back and
explain something or you know go through
a part of the code or anything you need
rook says those error messages are nice
they tell you the file the line and the
character spot callin yeah for sure
they're they're really nice saves a lot
of time
rook says is that link clickable the
error link let's see
check our terminal so these aren't
clickable but maybe you're talking about
the error that comes up here
let's try let me do something that gives
me an air link I can't click on that
pop-up maybe let me try to do
do something like this
it doesn't look like anything in here is
clickable whoa oh that was the gate I've
never type clicked on the the get thing
all right I'm just gonna get out of
there cuz it's confusing me change 101
it was just showing me the changes that
I made all right cool
anyway Brooke I don't know if I was
trying to click the right thing but it
didn't look like any of that stuff was
was clickable you know what all this
calculating stuff is not working right I
wonder if some of my plugins in Visual
Studio code or what's causing my
computer to run maybe this plugin is
cool but I really don't need it maybe I
should go ahead and shut off some of the
stuff I don't don't really use off to
check on that just a thought
so harsh had said yeah rook that's a
mate so it is clickable I must have just
been trying to click the wrong thing
then huh
that vote prio says how to get the
terminal on Visual Studio code to look
like in the video you know what I got
these colors from Udacity z-- intro to
get in github course it's a free course
check it out I think they have to get
courses now the older one was taught by
two women
so do that one if you want to know these
colors and they gave some an example
file to change all your colors for your
terminal and I just took the example I
didn't even really change it I just like
the colors so that's where I got it from
the git and github Ares I think it's
called intro to get in github on Udacity
it's it's one of their free courses
haha alright Harshit so earlier i was
talking about tests and writing tests
for this and harsh it says jesse you
also haven't written a test yet with a
little winking smiley face are [ __ ] you
are right oh man I just got caught out
yeah I have not written the test yet
I I will say this I have slightly
modified some existing tests not for
this project but from previous ones but
I haven't written one a test on my own
so harshly keeps me honest I didn't I
didn't say I wrote a test I just
encouraged everyone to writes head yes I
need to learn more about writing tests
myself and yeah hard [ __ ] has I've done
all the tests for this project so thank
you for that
oh I guess so we used get push earlier
that only works if you have set the
tracking branch already so thanks
Harshit and on hell for clarifying that
how harsh that my phone got the Oreo
update I hate these new emoji I don't
remember what the emoji were like was
like before the Oreo update maybe that's
better then I won't be bothered by the
new ones
other words so um Oh Oh USS oath
house let me know if I'm pronouncing
that wrong I'm not really sure to
pronounce that but anyway they say can I
tell you something I subscribe to your
channel but I never watch your videos
this is mainly because they look too
advanced and the thumbnails do and miss
a lot of fundamental stuff in my opinion
when I watch some of your tutorials you
go too fast but I still watched some of
your videos though I'm not really hating
on your channel I respect what you do
all right cool I appreciate the
constructive criticism yeah so I will
say this if I ever go too fast you're
welcome to ask some questions ask me to
go back I'm happy to do that but also so
the different videos on this channel on
free code camp channel serve different
purposes if you maybe want a more
fundamental tutorial check out some of
those JavaScript videos I mean it
depends on what you want to learn but
for instance bow is a lot of basic level
JavaScript all the way up to more
advanced stuff this particular series
live coding with Jessie is not really a
tutorial it's more of just showcasing my
everyday work so I think the biggest
benefit to this aside from the awesome
community that we now have you know
around this the show is that I mess
things up frequently and then we get to
work through them live so you kind of
get an idea that usually in tutorials
you don't have that happen they're well
organized and things work whereas with
this stream things don't work and we
have to work at him often or sometimes
we just have to make things work and
it's like this is as good as it's gonna
get right now we have to you know think
of the trade-offs between doing it one
way or another so not everything is
perfect so that's it it makes sense that
sometimes it seems like it goes too fast
or we miss you know go to skip over
fundamental things so
I still appreciate you saying that and
like I said if you ever want me to
explain anything more or go back and do
something again let me know I'm happy to
do that but again I really appreciate
you saying that and the weight you said
it was very respectful I I definitely
appreciate that so thank you
Kemal says hey Jesse you're doing great
work please organize this tutorial in an
organized manner react fart and material
I part would be a great help
I even Kamal says I mean make the
reactive material UI part combine
playlists in organized way okay
yeah let me
I can probably separate out the
tutorials in a better way right now I
have like I say what project is from so
the title will say like this this one I
think was p5d
23 so it's project 5 day 23 what I will
do and I know I've been saying I'm going
to do this and I just haven't really
taken the time to is go through and
separate every project out into its own
playlist I haven't thought about doing
anything like this before but it's a
possibility that potentially I could
separate out certain topics into their
own playlists as well I don't know that
might be more confusing but I could do
something like here's where we do just
all back-end stuff here's where we
everything where I handle like sending
emails from a server or file uploads
there are some things that we seem to be
doing like every project it could be I
don't know let me know what what do you
think would be the best way to organize
these I'm still gonna have the one big
playlist that's just live coding with
Jesse so you can see everything in one
spot but I definitely it would be good
to have playlist for each project is
there any other way that I should try to
organize these as well I prefer I can't
go crazy with it cuz it's not my channel
I'll share it so I don't want to make a
million playlist but you know if there's
any reasonable way to organize it I'm
definitely open to suggestions
our Blake's here hey Blake how's it
going
oh okay so Kamal says please make a
playlist for react.js material you I
combined I don't know where to start
it's all messed up WordPress react node
I want react jazz only please make the
specific playlist for that hmm alright
yeah I'll have to think about how to do
that because there are times when we
switch back and forth so it may be a
little bit hard to just isolate react
because there are some streams where
we'll do node react WordPress all of it
in one stream sometimes it's hard to
just stick to one one thing I'll keep
that in mind and I'll try to think about
how I can organize them there are
definitely some videos that are like
obviously one thing or the other they
could maybe go into a playlist
John Henson says a pinch of cloves is
great when making a slow cooks too young
I don't know where that I guess are you
cooking John maybe I missed something in
the chat all says did I did he answer my
question I was gone for a second I did
answer your question I'm not sure you
can always check the recording let's see
Oh Umberto's says I found out recently
that our contract is getting renewed I
have no idea for how long yet but
hopefully that means I get to keep my
job for a while longer
I'm Baird so that's awesome really
awesome yeah so I mean I guess let me
know let me know if you do get to keep
it and if you're back in the market
looking for a job let me know too
I'd be happy to like I don't know
retweet stuff for you I hope you get
some exposure savage banana says Becca
yeah that's yeah my wife's name is Becca
so I guess you did go and look it up on
social me
all right cool Harshit says all right we
might be on to something how harsh it
said that that import cost plug-in is
CPU intensive and it crashed it crashed
his computer once so remove import cost
all right cool so either today or
tomorrow I'm gonna try to run on 1080p
with that plug-in gone and then see if
it makes a difference
see
Harshit said i messed up pronunciation
of Kemal sorry about that let me know
I'm supposed to pronounce it properly I
really I do care about pronouncing
everyone's name right so let me know
don't be afraid to correct me if I if I
ever say your name wrong
all right so all says I think camo is
right when you organize your projects in
their own playlist it would be more
attractive and more inviting the thing
is I'm a software engineer and worked
with JavaScript a lot with but with the
new es6 and the new things like babel
and import and export and how that stuff
works like that freaks me out sometimes
or the observed thingies it's not that I
don't understand JavaScript just the new
things the JavaScript frameworks offered
but if you have videos or tutorials
where you group them in playlists it
would be so much better in my opinion I
work mainly with c-sharp and PHP okay
cool that's good that's good to know
thanks for the clarification yeah so I
would say probably it would be more like
I can still look at maybe organizing
things differently but I would I would
say trying to maybe find some specific
videos maybe in like Bo's JavaScript
playlist that have to do with es6 and
some of the newer things might need more
helpful to you and then if you want to
still watch the stream which is awesome
if you do it'll help you to understand
more of it and I'm still open to
answering any questions that you have as
well Nicola says it's it's kind of hard
to give a name to a live stream because
you don't know exactly what you will
finish at the end yeah for sure the
hardest part about live streaming is
figuring out what title to give the
videos no lie that's the hardest part
because you're right I just never know
sometimes I title a stream and then I
don't even get it to work at all or we
end up having like some bug and we can
fix that so that is the hardest part
even if I did we're gonna have some into
playlists I'd probably still have some
things that weren't right because of
that because I sometimes we just don't
actually do what the title says we do
and then
never go back and change it which I
should Oh says a study now is a software
architect and my sequel database and
stuff anyways yeah that was that was it
I think one more thing might pronounce
my name is pronounced like boss okay
cool thank you for the pronunciation
I'll do my best to try to remember that
us us okay awesome John says yes cooking
painting and thinking code soon off to
the gym wow that's impressive cooking
painting and thinking about code that's
that's really impressive
i I don't know if I can handle all that
at once and still you know not burn the
food
all right harsh it says to paste and see
the pronunciation and translate all
right cool let me do that right now
come on come on come on
all right I'm trying I'm trying to
listen and get it right it's really like
subtle
come on all right I don't know I'm gonna
try my best to get it right I'm having
trouble with that one though
hard said to John Hansen I looked at
your website your oil paintings are
awesome they are awesome check out
John's website if you're into artwork
he's a really good artist and if you
still haven't checked out his lite-brite
react app on code pen check that out as
well
I tweeted about it last week or
something so check out my Twitter and
scroll down a bit and you'll see a link
to it that debo prio
says thank you for answering my
questions Jesse you're welcome thanks
for watching the stream and being so
active in the chat I really appreciate
it
alright so I've gotten to the end of the
live chat and I tell you what I think
I'm gonna wait till tomorrow to finish
up with with what we were doing because
I'm a little bit tired I'd like I'd like
a little break like to get something to
eat and also now it gives me a good
title for the stream tomorrow because I
can use the same title and just put part
two so that that makes it a lot easier
for me oh we got one more question Vivek
says bro tell me how can I do my best in
Python
well I don't know a lot about Python
specifically I do like Python I've used
it a little bit but I can give you some
general advice on how to how to do your
best and I should make a video about
this because I think I've said this you
know a few times now in the stream at
different times but when you're trying
to learn any coding stuff Python
included when your strategy for for
learning more I think should be if you
can break it up and learn a little bit
every day that's so much better than
maybe like let's say every Saturday just
doing all day on Saturday your brain
will when your brain is trying to learn
something new it's trying to make these
little pathways and connections right
with the neurons in your brain I'm not a
scientist so if I'm not using the
correct terms
I mean it is what it is but the more you
make pathways like think of if you're
taking a hike in the woods right if you
walked over the grass every single day a
little bit every day the the grass and
everything would get beat down and
there'd be a path if you only did it
once a week it probably wouldn't
wouldn't happen the grass would have
enough time to grow up and so you
wouldn't have that nice path it's the
same way with your brain so that will
help if you can do a little bit every
day you can do a lot every day it'll
help even more but that's my number one
piece of advice when you're trying to
learn something you'll retain and all
it's so much better and try to build on
it right so when you learn one thing
don't just move on to another concept
and never use it again try to
immediately apply what you learned to a
project so do your tutorials but then
try to have a project go on at the same
time and apply it that helps so much
when I was learning react with udacity I
would immediately use what I learned in
Udacity on my projects at work and the
stuff we did in the stream and so I
remembered it's so much better so then
when I actually got to the point in the
Udacity course where I had to build my
own project I had retained a lot of the
knowledge from the lectures and and the
little exercises that we had done along
the way because I'd already used it so
that's just kind of my general advice I
think it can be applied safely to a lot
of different things in programming and
probably to other fields as well I mean
I don't know if you have like any
specific areas about Python I don't know
how much I can help because I I don't
know that much about Python
[Applause]
Harshit says here's some more specific
advice this is good so harsh it says
make service or learn AI since there's a
huge scope for Python Nicola says which
time tomorrow will you stream in your
time I'm trying to stream I've been
trying to stream earlier around noon it
seems like a better time for
four time zones that are like in India
and that area of the world
so maybe noon or 1:00 p.m. Eastern Time
in my time so sometimes I have things
going on and I can't stick to a time but
expected sometime around there Vivek
says which fuel is more appropriate in
the future a IR networking I don't know
a I just it seems like it's really cool
these days so harsh it's answer is good
says AI is really hot these days but
there's always need of networking yeah
yeah I mean I tend to agree it does I I
think they'll both still be useful and
around for a long time if I had to pick
honestly assuming that I could safely
get a job in either one and support my
family I'd pick AI because that just
seems it seems really cool to work on or
should also says you should be good at
math in math right okay it's cool it's
good to know that's some good specific
advice there are should also says
networking is easier to learn ib chick
says ionic or react native for Android
I recommend react native I think react
native has some advantages over using
ionic it lets you use like some more of
like the lower level stuff that you nut
won't necessarily have access to if
you're using ionic now I haven't checked
into ionic for years so maybe it's it's
different now but as far as I know I
think react native gives is the better
way to go
vivix says what time do you stream in
India I don't know for sure there might
be multiple time zones in India but for
harsh its time zone which I need
hardships in the Himalayas but for that
time zone noon would be like 11 p.m.
right let me know harsh it is 12 my 12
p.m. my time 11 p.m. for you it's
somewhere around there it might not be
exactly 11 but I think it's that's close
Vivek says I'm stuck in many things I
can't decide my future yeah that's tough
Vivek I mean right now just do what you
can with what you have and don't worry
about what you can't control you know
that way at least you can make progress
with with what you do and if it turns
out you can end up doing more and have
you know some more freedom in your
decisions at some point then you'll be
prepared let's see Xavier says any way
to contribute to your projects there
used to be an option in free code camp
to make websites for charities like for
free yeah I'm not sure how that works
with the charities thing and free code
camp but you can definitely contribute
to these projects check out the
repositories that we have and you know
go to the link check out that whole
github organization and any of the
repositories just look at the look at
the issues that are open and you can
take one of those and work on it or if
you notice some glaring flaw you can
open your own issue and you'll work on
that if you want if you need any help or
ideas just just let me know
oh cool good to know Vivek says there's
only one timezone in India it's GMT all
right very good to know that's cool
that's nice there's one time zone in in
the US we have so many times on
sometimes it's when you're traveling and
within the country like it can be
confusing sometimes as you pass through
time zones
it's like depending on which way you're
going it either seems like you gain a
lot of time or you lost a lot of time
abhishek says which libraries should we
use for employing machine learning and
web apps I I really don't know I don't
know enough about that I know there is
some machine learning JavaScript
libraries out there
oh I don't remember offhand with they're
called though but they do exist if
you're gonna use them in web apps you
may as well use Java scripts because
you're going to be using it anyway since
it's a web app so that would be my
recommendation I don't know if you can
run machine learning stuff client-side I
assume you'd have to run it server-side
with node I don't know if it would kind
of be cool if those are really something
really lightweight that you can do basic
machine learning stuff in the client but
I I don't think that exists I think it's
to resource intensive
oh wow lebesgue says it's 1:15 a.m. it
is it is 246 p.m. right now where I am
Abby shakes us is it advisable to learn
to JavaScript frameworks at the same
time I wouldn't try to do it myself I'd
rather focus on one and learn it really
well the only way I would do that is if
I I wasn't sure whether I wanted to do
one or the other and I just wanted to
learn the basics of both to make a
decision but I think it's better to
choose I always I think I mentioned this
before in a stream but I read it really
like an old book once but it was about
basically like ways to live your life to
help like improve your brain and your
intellect and it was one of the things
that it had said was was basically and
this is my own words was if you really
want to be good at something you have to
say no to everything else so right if
you really want to be good at react you
say no to angular in view if you really
want to be you know and it works with
anything in life not just programming it
doesn't mean you can't do those other
things but you can't do it at the same
level right you have to focus there are
some people who can be good at a lot of
different things but if they would just
pick one they could be great at it so if
you want to really be great and like one
of the best that's something you're
gonna have to pick other things which is
like I mean that that's kind of freeing
and restrictive in the same time because
it almost gives you license to be able
to focus and you'd be okay with that but
but you do have to decide so I guess
just think about that some people may
rather just be kind of good at a lot of
things or even really good at a lot of
things but to get to that best level you
do have to choose and so that's why I
would say
one framework well and be really awesome
at it that's what I would do but leisa
it does depend a little bit on your
goals and what your intention is for
learning both of them all right I mean
if you're in a company that uses both
obviously you have to learn both if
you're a freelancer and you want to open
yourself up to more clients yeah I learn
both but if you have the freedom to be
able to pick one and stick with it I
would do that Oh Vivek says for machine
learning tensorflow is good it's
developed by Google that's right yeah I
I do remember hearing good things about
tensorflow haven't used it yet but I've
just heard good things
Harshit says javascript is terrible in
machine learning use Python since 95
percent uses tensorflow Harshit is
making an AI chat bot vivek asks where I
lived in America I live in Ohio I
actually live right on the border of
Ohio in Pennsylvania and West Virginia
like they all meet at one place so I
live the big city that I'm closest to is
Pittsburgh so I'm pretty close to
Pittsburgh and so I'm in the Eastern
time zone so like New York City is in
the same time so that I'm in the whole
East Coast of the United States is in
that time zone
a harsher she said Steubenville Ohio
you remembered yes student bill is a
small city like I don't like 16,000
people and sumo I think
Vivek says Ohio have their own
University yeah so Ohio has a lot of
universities so there's a university
here in Steubenville and that's what
that's the university I work for it's
Franciscan University of student oh
there's a in it so it's an independent
school but there are state schools that
are like government-funded so Ohio State
is the big state school I believe it's
the largest university in the state of
Ohio and then there's there's a lot of
other small universities so small and
there are some other state universities
as well so there's this a lot but Ohio
is one of the more important states in
the United States several like major
cities and things I'm not originally
from Ohio though I'm from West Virginia
which is one of the least important
states but I love it I love my home
state vivek says what job do you do I am
a I'm officially a front-end developer
but realistically I I do a lot of
backend stuff as well but my title is
front-end developer and if you'd like to
know more about what I do just check out
the stream because I'm streaming this
from my job so this is my my actual work
that I'm doing each day on the stream
the stuff you don't see you're basically
me sitting in meetings answering emails
and sending messages on slack but like
my real work is exactly the same as what
I've stream
here's another question and Wow alright
I'm gonna have trouble with this name
I'm gonna do my best read jesh Rajesh
Khanna I'm really sorry if I messed that
up says how to improve my web design
skill alright if you want to know more
about design
I recommend read through some the
material design documentation just to
get an idea of like the the logic behind
design which you have to think about and
then check out some other designs so
like there are websites that like give
awards for the best website designs like
check those out just kind of look at
what's new and design things you like
and don't like and and then just try
things out you'll get a feel once you
look at enough design and work with it
enough you'll start to get a feel for
what works and what doesn't just by
looking at it you'll be able to look and
say no those colors don't work I need
more white space this needs to be a few
pixels one way or the other like it
takes a while to get that but eventually
you like you'll get it and I'm not
saying I'm the best of design but you
know I'm definitely at the point where I
can look at something and say this will
look better if it were adjusted a few
pixels or those colors definitely don't
work and at that point and then you know
even beyond I'm sure there are people
that are even so much better at that and
can come up with an awesome design like
you know right off just off the top of
their head on a piece of paper or
something but that would be my advice
just kind of check out the designs that
are prominent now read about why they do
it and check out some of the websites
that are really getting like recognized
for having good design
let's say a B Shaykh says how to make
SVG responsive and web pages hard said
media queries
yeah media queries so I'll tell you what
check out some of the videos by Sarah
Dresner she's really good with SVG's and
so check out some of her stuff I've
heard some of her talks before where she
covers like responsiveness and SVG's and
it's actually a lot better to use SVG's
as opposed to normal images if you want
things to look right on different
screens because there's I know there's
really cool stuff that you can do
there's so much you can do with SVG so I
check out some of her stuff if you want
to learn more about it but essentially
yes like media queries work a lot using
like percentage widths instead of like a
fixed width you know helps a lot but I
think was Sarah Dresden yeah that's DRA
s and ER VFX says bro you live in
America it's great but I live in India
it's also great but I want to get a job
in Google California yeah it'd be great
to work at Google they have you make a
lot of money there's like a great a lot
of like perks to working at Google like
you most likely have access to a lot of
awesome technology they also have a lot
of different locations worldwide as well
so I mean it'd be cool to live in
California I wouldn't want to live there
though cuz it's really really expensive
to try to find a house or an apartment
in California but Google does have other
locations like they actually have a
location in Pittsburgh which would be
really cool to work at I could I could
live in the same house I live at now
just commute into Pittsburgh and work at
Google there if they'll have me if
anybody from Google is watching I mean
give me a call
maybe we'll see
and I like my job right now and where
I'm at but I probably would not turn
down something from Google it's just a
great opportunity assuming I would be
even good enough to work there I don't
know about that let's see whoa-ohh-ohh
sauce just put a lyric up from
countryroads which is basically like the
theme the theme song of my home state of
West Virginia so you just made my heart
feel like longing for my homeland right
now just from that lyric so I'm gonna be
singing that song all day every true
West Virginian knows all the words to
that song and can sing it whenever it
comes on so how did you know about that
song I really appreciate that that's
awesome you put that in let's see
oh yeah so they're saying Sarah Dresner
works at Microsoft yeah yeah see where
some Microsoft she's really active on
Twitter as well you check out her
Twitter stuff she has she's spoken at a
ton of different conferences she's on a
lot of different YouTube channels for
different things she I think she has a
talk on free code camps talk Channel so
free code cam has two different channels
if you check out their talk channel then
I think she's on there but yeah
everything I've ever seen her do with
SVG's is just amazing
her should said Jessie they will
probably not higher react engineer as
Facebook yeah I don't I assumed might be
doing other things and not react I don't
does Google use react for anything I
don't know maybe they do yeah so maybe
I'd be doing other stuff but I mean they
gotta have people write JavaScript right
they have a lot of website so I'd
probably be doing something with
JavaScript I do use a lot of material
design and Google Google invented that
so maybe maybe there's a shot for me
John Hanson says it's for you Google's
calling yeah be crazy if they actually
did call me during a stream at some
point all right I've gotten to the end
of the live chat finally alright so I
think I'm gonna stop for real this time
thanks everyone for watching we we did
some good stuff didn't get everything
done that I wanted to but the work that
we did it works oh that's that's a plus
so I'll be back tomorrow I'm gonna try
to stream some time around like noon or
1 p.m.
another question says would you
recommend for me to go into App Academy
I'm not sure exactly what app Academy is
but my recommendation for any type of
thing like that or bootcamp or something
is check it out to make sure that
they're legitimate and see like do
people really get jobs from this check
on the price if you can afford it and
you can take the time and it seems like
it's a reputable thing then go for it
I've never done anything like that so I
can't tell you personally but like my
wife's doing a bootcamp right now and
she seems to be really happy with it so
without knowing more details that's just
kind of my general advice
all right so now let me get out of here
I'm really hungry at this point so I
actually do want to end the stream and
get something to eat so thanks so much
everyone for watching I'll be back
tomorrow until then have a great day